et le réveillant
avoir deux commence alors
pas de répit pour les skippers évinois
du vendée globe pendant les fêtes de
noël
éric bellion et louis burton ont dû
affronter des vagues de plusieurs mètres
loin de leurs proches
le navigateur de l'imoca comme un seul
homme a réussi à passer l'australie et
se positionne à la 10e place du
classement
c'est cool merci
pourtant le jour de noël le hasard a
voulu qu éric bellion pas cette journée
aux côtés des skippers en dao coenen et
à l'amour après 50 jours de course c'est
le plus beau noël de ma vie quoi d'avoir
ces trois bateaux 3 imoca du vendée
globe tout près là c'est extraordinaire
vraiment de son côté louis burton
remonte laurent politain désormais 7e de
la course suite à l'abandon de thomas
ruyant
je suis très content même si là en ce
moment c'est un petit peu calme de la
position de bureau vallée et je j'espère
arriver au cap horn dans trois jours
après le cap horn il restera un peu plus
d'un mois en mer l'occasion de
grappiller encore quelques places au
classement